[Applause]
just two and a half hours from West
Lafayette the home of the Boilermakers
right is fun turns the corner then Clark
Erickson fundamental as they get filled
owning the paint making sure he keeps
attacking Scofield just picked up a
second foul Ryan Klein it is an
unorthodox shop an outstanding defender
and he's already had a couple of steals
in this game has two assists as well his
client again the quick release headaches
a three line fishing all day long into
the basket you can call it a hitch you
could call
man say hey coach harms is doing a great
job inside I'm trying to get some mixed
client again that's a long tool for Iong
time he's hot
and here's time the three is up
fine it's another one body
single-handedly keeping his team in it
but look at climb with the beautiful 12
and a half for Admiral Schofield club
man does he have a quick trigger motel
Eastern get to the fly
[Applause]
and go with the pick-and-roll with he
and efforts or at least the dribble
vehicle is flying again folks he got
another one at him
[Applause]
24 points look at crime I mean this is
just dead
that's right and shot clock down to 9
fly can't dribble himself free he's
gonna have to take a long one fine step
back 3 for the time this dude 22 second
half points 27 for the game for Ryan
Klein the benches react